bonjour de bruxelles est bien sûr très
bonne amie vient alors cette année au
parlement européen elle commence par
l'actualité qui était attendu et qui est
l'actualité du bric si cette semaine les
députés britanniques ont validé l'accord
de sortie de l'union européenne proposée
par boris johnson et maintenant les
négociations vont s'engager entre la
grande bretagne et l'union européenne
pendant un an
pour acter les conditions de sortie de
lion dans ce contexte il ya une autre
la décision qui a été prise par les
députés britanniques et qui concerne le
programme emblématique et erasmus cette
semaine les députés ont également
augmenté
c'était très technique mais une clause
qui empêche la poursuite de certaines
discussions qui auraient permis aux
britanniques de rester dans ce programme
il faut attendre de voir comment ça
évolue mais ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
voilà c'est une des premières
conséquences qu'on peut juger comme
négative du mexique notamment pour les
citoyens européens les citoyens
britanniques bien sûr et aussi pour les
citoyens français puisque nous sommes le
premier pays à envoyer des étudiants des
jeunes des enseignantes en grande
bretagne pour suivre ce programme
emblématique de l'union européenne donc
finalement il n'ya pas illogique quand
on veut détricoter le sentiment européen
et l'attachement à l'union européenne
on s'attaque à ce programme emblématique
qui fait le ciment d'union